but first it's my brain dump
as vladimir putin butchers ukraine
millions of ordinary russians are forced
for a daily diet of sex propaganda to
convince him of his warped alternative
reality and there's no such thing as a
free press to tell the truth or hold
into account putin's russia is a country
where journalists are routinely murdered
literally thrown out of windows
reporting the facts they face 15 years
in jail for criticizing his evil war or
the special military operation as he so
disingenuously calls it
here in our free world brave journalists
are risking their lives daily so that we
know exactly what is going on in ukraine
where the barbaric dictator is waging
genocide in a democratic sovereign
country
in putin's russia even his closest
allies set a football field away from
their slayer in chief
but here in our free world comedians
considered a few meters away from the
president of the united states hurling
zingers at him as if he was the groom at
a wedding
you know i was a little confused about
why me
but then i was told that you get your
highest approval ratings when a biracial
african guy is standing next to you so
uh
so let me just say uh joe
i'm glad that i could uh do my part
i think ever since you've come into
office things are really looking up you
know gas is up rent is up food is up
everything this is truly the golden era
of conspiracy theories
whether it's the right wing believing
trump can still win the 2020 election or
the left believing joe biden can still
win the 2024 election
well that was trevor noah the white
house correspondents dinner an annual
event in washington but journalists who
spend their lives scrutinizing and
criticizing the president of the united
states without fear of being killed and
amid the glamour the black tie and the
comedy there was a very serious point
here and noah made it rather beautifully
in america you have the right
to seek the truth and speak the truth
even if it makes people in power
uncomfortable even if it makes your
viewers or your readers uncomfortable
understand how amazing that is
i stood here tonight and i made fun of
the president of the united states and
i'm gonna be fine
i'm gonna be fine right
can you ever imagine putin president g
in china or north korea's kim jong-un
attending a celebration for journalists
whose job it is to shine a light on
their incompetence or allowing
themselves to be publicly ridiculed on
national television we all know what
would happen to a tv star like trevor
noah who dare make jokes like that at
their expense in those oppressive
totalitarian regimes and that's why we
should never take any of our freedoms
for granted and that's why this couldn't
have come at a more as a more timely
reminder of how important it is to live
in a country with a free press and
freedom of speech
well just as mere tough talk and
sanctions won't end this war we can't
defeat putin the demon by demonizing
ordinary russians
tennis stars from russia and belarus are
barred from competing at the wimbledon
grand slam tournament this year over the
ukraine invasion it means that two of
the top 10 best men's players in the
world won't be at the world's premier
tennis competition that's despite both
of them courageously speaking out
against the war and calling for peace
well tennis superstars like novak
djokovic andy murray and rafa nadal have
now criticized the ban and i agree with
them
i think it is very unfair for my russian
mates my colleagues in that sense poor
them there's not much they can do
poor them at the end of the day it is
not their fault what is happening in
this moment with the war
first off this reeks of hypocrisy did
wimbledon ban stan smith jimmy connors
or john mcenroe during the wildly
unpopular wars waged by america in
vietnam iraq or afghanistan of course
they didn't and what about the ill-fated
and what many of you is a legal invasion
of iraq by the us and uk
andre agassi andy roddick and serena
williams all won tennis grand slams in
2003 applying this new logic that had
been banned from taking part there's
also been no clamor to ban saudi arabian
athletes over their country's bloody war
in yemen which is no less reprehensible
than russia's war in ukraine
in fact saudi arabia hosted a formula
one grand prix just a few weeks ago and
its athletes compete in the olympics
i fully support blocking russian
national teams who represent the russian
state under the russian flag but
targeting the country's individuals for
blame over the behavior of their
despotic leader doesn't make sense and
it's part of a worrying trend
we've seen russian sports stars heckled
russian arts being cancelled around the
world russian products being boycotted
even stupidly summoned to sound russian
russian restaurants blacklisted even
though some of them are run by
ukrainians the city of oxford even
daubed over this site because it used to
be partnered with perm and russia this
is all pointless tokenism it won't work
and it hurts the wrong people dictators
depend on stoking fear and hatred of the
outside world this is all just
ammunition for putin's propaganda drive
cancelling russian sport and culture
won't win this war
well speaking of alternative realities
the conservative mp caught watching porn
in the house of commons keeping global
embarrassment on britain's democracy has
fallen on his sword no pun intended
sadly it wasn't without one last blast
of cringe-worthy squirming neil parish
who's also a farmer first brazenly
called for an investigation to the
allegations allowing rumors to swirl
about his own colleagues when he knew
he'd done it and he tried to explain it
all the way with an excuse was frankly
utterly ridiculous
the uh situation was that that um i um
funnily enough it was tractors that i
was looking at and um so i did get into
another website um that had a very
similar name
um and i watched it for a bit which i
shouldn't have done who hasn't stumbled
across porn looking for tractors
it gets worse paris later briefed
specifically he was searching
for dominator combine harvesters
when a rather different kind of
dominator popped up
but there is a pathway to redemption for
hapless parish and it comes in this form
of his former conservative colleague
brooks newmark you may not remember the
name the new mark quit as a british
government minister in 2014 after
newspapers exposed him by sending lewd
photos to a reporter posing as a young
female fan
for years after we never really heard
anything about him again but now it's
emerged that new mark has risked his
life to almost single-handedly save over
seven and a half thousand ukrainian
women and children in the past two
months helping him evacuate the war zone
he raised three hundred thousand dollars
from friends and family to begin a bus
service taking refugees out of ukraine
from sinner to savior
good for him
now i don't believe in cancer culture so
i was obviously distraught to learn that
the woman who canceled me has now
herself been cancelled
yes netflix has shelved the development
of pearl an animated series created by
meghan markle with sir elton john's
husband david furnish about a 12 year
old girl inspired by influential women
apparently it was based on her own very
inspiring rags to royal rich's story but
sadly it seems nobody at netflix
shared my inspiration
the streaming giant reported very bad
results last week a direct consequence
some critics say they're increasingly
tedious woke output including a new
series about a pregnant man
netflix stock tanks so they've had to
pull the plug on megan's vanity project
to cut costs and concern is now mounting
that the duke and duchess of netflix's
whole hundred million dollar deal with
the company may now be in jeopardy
none of this brings me any pleasure
especially
after the sad failure of her
nauseatingly patronizing children's boat
the bench
but it would be remiss of me not to just
politely suggest that megan and harry
may be suddenly discovering that maybe
the rest of the world isn't quite as
excited by their self-righteous brand of
pious hypocritical money-grabbing virtue
signaling royal bashing as they are
because let's face it when the world's
wokest production company axes the
world's wokest project by the world's
wokest celebrity that's a whole new
level of humiliation i wish megan
sincerely all the very best at this
difficult time